and number two you have to outside of
your job build your skills in this world
otherwise you will be vulnerable period
this morning really nice to meet you
guys I'd love to do as much QA as
possible I'll pick it up from that point
in 2009 on the back of a lot of success
early in my life especially by investing
in Facebook and Twitter it became very
obvious to me that the world was about
to go through a substantial change and
that this internet thing was far bigger
than what i even thought as a kid and
that we were just in the beginning not
the end and i think sometimes especially
for you guys like you know how timing is
right you think it's over like it's like
a band you like you think it's over but
they didn't even start getting big even
though you've been on for a year and a
half that's kind of how i thought about
the internet as a whole my father-in-law
was jim kilts his right hand marketing
guy at Nabisco Kraft and Gillette and so
at family functions barbecues and random
times I would hear them talk about big
brands and and they were winning like
they were like considered like winning
and like they were doing all the right
things every company had turned around
and then something very interesting
happened I went on vacation with my wife
and I don't really read a lot of books
ever like a bread like 9:00 in my life
but one of them was about the private
equity firm 3G which went on to buy
Budweiser and Kraft and Heinz and I was
reading it and just kind of this series
of like you know life is funny sometimes
it's about getting the pieces together
at the right moment and having the time
to think and really the only time I
think is on this vacation and so I'm
kind of walking the beach and it kind of
like kind of out of like a central
casting movie I was like [ __ ] it just
all clicked which is huh if 3G is gonna
win and I think they are and this was in
2009 for buying Burger King firing
everybody maximizing profit
Wall Street's gonna like that that made
sense to me at Facebook and Twitter and
YouTube are gonna win televisions gonna
get disrupted even more so and I thought
it was already dead by commercials
standards you know and
as we're here this week it's still very
much on an emotional pedestal and so I
basically started putting things
together in my mind and saying wow
private-equity these brands and then I
really thought Amazon was a very big
company at the time and it's now been
proven to be that and I was like I think
retail is in trouble you know my dad
this business that we were referring to
my dad had a liquor store in New Jersey
I launched one of the first three
e-commerce wine businesses in America
and just everything just kind of came
together
my brother was graduating college we
wanted to start a business together and
then ESPN a week later asked me to come
in and consult and they said we'll give
you $5,000 for an hour and I was like
[ __ ] and so it was all kind of coming
together and I was like you know there's
it might be time for me to leave Silicon
Valley I'd done the entrepreneur
entrepreneur like real entrepreneurs yet
not this new tech version like being in
a liquor store 15 hours a day for 10
years I need to figure out this
corporate America thing because it's big
and it's wrong and so knowing that I was
a DNF student I couldn't go MBA it out
or hire a couple people I just don't
learn that way I was like let me go eat
[ __ ] for a decade I'm gonna build an
agency I didn't even know what that
meant I called my company vaynermedia we
only did creative for the first four
years like I didn't know that media and
creative was separate I know when I tell
you I knew nothing like I never heard of
WPP or David Ogilvy or any I mean I was
34 years old starting an agency and
never heard anything that this that
you'll hear the whole day like I didn't
know what Ken was I didn't know what a
Dage was I didn't know what widening
Kennedy was I know nothing here's what I
knew I knew that the end consumer wasn't
being communicated to properly and that
within the first six months and 10 or 15
meetings and a little bit of reading I
knew the whole thing was trading on the
wrong things here's the amazing
advantages when you don't come from the
world a couple things when you walk into
the world and you find out that Nielsen
ratings are super important to justify
things
you do what a new person does like me
who's an operator you try to figure out
how Nielsen ratings are being measured
but you realize very quickly is like
holy [ __ ] this is mathematically correct
but not practically correct you can't
have two thousand boxes and people
calling people and asking them if they
watch Charlie Rose last night to figure
out if like it was absurd and the
absurdity continued every day and so
with a couple things that I'd like to
establish number one I think creative is
the variable of success for brands so
I'm not a mathematician or a quant guy
or you know to me just do it where's the
beef
priceless is the Holy Grail
when you produce something that gets
everybody to know that's how the human
brain makes decisions it's not because
we cookie them and follow them around
and by my problem though is I'm also
unbelievably practical my whole life has
been my work has to put food on the
table not win awards not get headlines
not get me a promotion so I've always
cared if it works there isn't a
commercial today that works because
nobody's watching television commercials
that's just the truth and that's a truth
we in the creative community have to
start accepting because otherwise we're
gonna have this rub and otherwise women
continue to see what we're seeing which
is the biggest brands in the world over
the last seven years have declined
massively they're losing market share
every day and we have to start having
the proper conversation and so to me
we're in this amazing perfect time now
where it's never been better to be a
creative you have unlimited flexibility
it's like being in production in
Hollywood it's great now everyone's
winning because there's Hulu and Amazon
Prime and Netflix and HBO and cable
there's so many places to sell your work
Hollywood's figured it out and everyone
you know they were [ __ ] on Netflix
five years ago now they're like kissing
its face because it opened up everything
um
I literally I'd love for the front row
to see us I'm huge goosebumps right now
because as I'm saying it I'm so
passionate cuz I love this space cuz you
know the thing that sucks about being in
something in ten years you meet people
and you like them and then you'll just
like the thing right I love this
industry I hate that it hasn't figured
out that the
second they put the romance of
television away we will all flourish I
don't know what to say there is no just
do it commercial over the last 10 years
there isn't a commercial that is driven
business like they used to in the 70s
and 80s and 90s because people don't
watch them out and now on the flip side
Super Bowl is the best piece of
advertising opportunity in the world to
me the Super Bowl commercial is the
number one place I would spend money on
a TV spot but it's a singular unit
literally the Oscars and the Tonys and
the NFC Championship game and the world
could all that's a garbage people don't
watch it it's black and white and so um
Hollywood to their credit quickly got
off their [ __ ] and said [ __ ] it
because the economics were there when
Netflix started writing big checks it
was fine right the reason we haven't is
that's not what happened the reason it
hasn't happened in our world is because
the holding companies aren't
incentivized to change there's nothing
else to say that's just real life
business there's more margin in selling
programmatic digital and selling
television than any other category thus
that is the continued propaganda of our
industry to the demise of creative work
the fact that you can make a 17-minute
film on Facebook that if it was [ __ ]
awesome and you planned the media
properly would really sell and make
people excited is amazing you know the
work that I'm most proud of that
vaynermedia are all long-form videos
facebook says don't do it because it
doesn't work for their three-second
views you know the brand's don't want us
to do it nobody wants us to do it but
every time we do it miraculously the
product sells at supermarkets and
Walmart's and things of that nature and
that's even with that the risk of the
creative missing right and it still
works because it's so being consumed in
those environment yet unfortunately and
I have a lot of empathy for this room
you don't grow up dreaming about writing
one singular tweet like for Wendy's or
Moonpie that can change its business
it's just not what you're here for we're
not here in this sunny [ __ ] place
right for a you know the pedestal isn't
about a one minute 19 second video
that's a pre-roll on YouTube before
something else it's just not what's on a
pedestal and it's wrong and it's wrong
and I believe that and so I'm very
passionate to continue to communicate
that
and and what really bugs me the most is
that when you think about audio the rise
of audio sonic advertising the fact that
every brand now should have a jingle and
a three-second sound that we can
associate with the fact that you can
make five minute videos consider like
the fact that you can make eleven videos
for a brand instead of one is in theory
amazing for creative like wouldn't you
want to make eleven videos instead of
one wouldn't you want to look at this
room nobody here looks the same
shouldn't if I'm dub make one for
african-american females make one for
white guys with blond hair make one with
four psychographic demographic financial
interests should and I the answer is yes
but the system forces us to do a
subjective vanilla tagline that should
work for everybody and then make one
thirty [ __ ] second video that should
work for everyone
ok white people and the [ __ ] doesn't hit
and everybody who's smart knows it or
has looked up the biggest vulnerability
the reason if I'm talking right now he's
like huh is you just haven't looked up
cuz you're in your [ __ ] and you should
be right you trying to win trying to
establish I get it just haven't looked
up and the thing that the reason I
continue to only do this event at this
place is is because I want you to win
and you're not gonna play in the my
friends your career will not play out
based on the tone of this festival you
will not live during the television
commercial on a pedestal era that is not
your career and the quicker you figure
that out the better you know and so you
know I and and I think that this group
is the most vulnerable because you're
even in this room if you're a young
protege of this system you're the most
vulnerable because you're being seduced
by it just makes sense this is an honor
to be here right so now you're now
you're in the [ __ ] vortex now you
want your face on a poster out there for
a 30-second spot for coca-cola and I
think that's a big [ __ ] mistake and I
know I'm right and deep down I know you
know I'm right and I know you know it
and so now the question becomes what do
you do
about it and so for me it's just a very
common-sense conversation a couple
things I would highly recommend you do
so it's actionable please do not
disrespect social networks every one of
them download and create for it on the
side start a side hustle sell peanut
butter direct on Amazon and do all the
creative on internet please learn the
skills because you do not you are the
most vulnerable creative generation
because when this actually fully hits
tilt in the next five to seven years
you're gonna be deep in your career and
you're gonna be judged for being part of
this machine and you're not gonna get
the best jobs because you're gonna be
dissed for being a person of the print
of the outdoor of the television of the
banner you will have to be very
thoughtful and by the way I'm a
historian if you don't believe me
go read what happened to everybody who
got killed during the transition of
radio to television go read of all the
executives all the brands all the
creatives that lost in the late 40s
through the early 60s when we had the
rub between radio becoming television as
the main platform the Internet is the
main platform guys I used to think that
you at all this town would wake up and
stop doing commercials I didn't realize
that OTT was gonna come and there'd be
no commercials
ABC NBC CBS they're all dead they're
gone
just a better time now so they're not
gonna exist just not how the OT T's are
gonna play so we're gonna be in a much
more fun creative world I think you're
gonna have to figure out how to
integrate brands into creative we're
start original shows like it's all
started soap operas right like who knows
where this takes us but please don't
when people become romantic of the past
we go into a bad place we accept that
socially we haven't accepted it in the
advertising industry we put something on
a pedestal that is completely irrelevant
to the end consumer is a Cohen how is a
television commercial penetrating your
life it's inconceivable and you're in
the industry
you don't see them and you're in the
industry so how does a normal person see
it so I'm very passionate about this and
I'm really passionate for you guys
especially and you have to doesn't mean
that the copywriting has never been more
important
you have 5000 places to put it in I
write different copy on Instagram than I
do on Facebook that I do on Twitter it's
the same [ __ ] audience but the
platform is different so I know their
psychology is different so I copy write
different like the first three seconds
of every video I think about differently
what's the platform what's the context
Twitter only lets me go for 240 or 280
Instagram is a minute Instagram is about
to be longer I'm already like spending
an enormous amount of time I'd like what
is long-form Instagram I mean because
that's where the attention is like there
is no fashion or cool brand that hasn't
been built on Instagram in the last
thirty six months you think champion
became champion on the back of
television commercials you think Stan
Smith's did that on TV
you think Lacroix did that on TV please
pay attention wears off whites
commercial what do think is happening so
I get it cuz you're in it and you guys
are really in it
everybody in industries in it you're
really in it cuz you're sitting here
right now and so it gets even more
dangerous and it's something you have to
think about because it's not gonna play
out we're not going backwards creative
is still the most important but creative
it gets redefined all the time right
I mean I built my dad's store a
newspaper copy let's call it what it is
it's email it was Google AdWords for
sure but I [ __ ] dominated newspapers I
would sit [ __ ] latest [ __ ] designing
that full-page ad in The New York Times
and it [ __ ] worked every time because
I knew the end consumer better than
anybody in the liquor business and I
knew and I got really really good at
understanding how to make a piece of
newspaper advertising to stop you as you
were going through the food section on
Wednesday in The New York Times you know
it was [ __ ] fun it was creative it
was interesting and then email and open
rates but
making one [ __ ] video and then
chopping it up for pre-roll programatic
[ __ ] what are we doing that's where I'm
at
questions yes sir what's your name
Harvey we what we're telling them is
it's wrong and this is what they should
do on Facebook
the problem is 89% of the time we can't
get them there
this was our big year we finally started
you know we got a pinnacle AOR thing we
became Budweiser's ALR thing we've got
some momentum and Mondelez I think 2019
is gonna be the year Vayner can help the
industry because I think we're in a
position to do enough work and then
there's also you know looking Jason
Hammond's who just went from the
vaynermedia production side - I bought
pure Wow a women's publishing company
and then last week I launched 137 p.m.
which is a men's publishing and we're
doing the branded content work but I
think there's a 2.0 version of that vice
refinery you know you know bleacher
report work and we're gonna be doing
that and it's a little bit more agency
centric even you know even though those
companies were good say agencies this is
like [ __ ] we're making agency work
but and we've already seen something
with Proctor very substantial on the on
the pure wild side I think this is gonna
be you know and then honestly that's
what I think my responsibility back to
oh so my my concept is I'm gonna buy
brands why did I start an agency because
I'm gonna buy k-swiss
or Mountain Dew or mug root beer or Head
& Shoulders I'm gonna buy brands the
brands are gonna die they're gonna when
the economy collapses they're gonna sell
for nothing because they're gonna have
to survive I'm gonna buy them and I'm
gonna build Procter & Gamble from the
ground up that's my 30-year mission
that's why I got in but while they're
paying me I feel an enormous
responsibility but it's I live this
bizarro world I'm desperately trying to
get them to do something yet as they
continue to do this stuff I just talked
about it's in my benefit long term
because it's why they're gonna die and
why I can buy them for cheap and I do
feel a huge responsibility while we're
an agency getting paid I have to give
the best advice first strategy first and
we do much to what I thought would
happen is happening they're not moving
but Budweiser's credit we did a bunch of
work last year it all worked the Jeter
stuff the Harry Caray stuff all that
stuff worked and an anomaly no longer
does the above the line work we do what
in essence is them new the new Budweiser
above the line work which is it starts
at Facebook and whatever works goes
above the line and it's really working
in sales because people see the Facebook
videos then honestly tell you yes
trust you at all when you tell them okay
this book should do
but they don't have much
yep I agree I agree no and I mean it
I'm what I think you need to do is two
things one if I'm you and this is now
per for you personally for your life for
you and your kids not like you need to
be on the record so that everybody in
this environment knows what your
opinions are the biggest fear I have for
you is you yes people to death because
you know what's accepted and then six
years later people judge you and be like
well I was in four meetings with you you
love TV [ __ ] you got it
so that's dangerous you need to find a
way of not getting fired but still
saying your piece so that it's on the
record and number two you have to
outside of your job build your skills in
this world otherwise you will be
vulnerable period and that's it and so
like you know that you're exactly right
I mean when I talk to beauty brands and
we work between my Vayner ex world
between vaynermedia and the Peru outside
we work with everybody
Unilever Proctor you know J&J L'Oreal
Revlon did it up i I just I have the
same meeting with all of them in the
last hundred days that was like do you
know how much Kylie Jenner's brand has
done direct-to-consumer in the last 12
months does anybody here know how much
revenue it's done in the first 12 months
revenue how much
that's exactly right 480 million dollars
in sales from zero because and by the
way it is not because she has so many
snapchat and Instagram followers and her
posts it's because they're marketing on
social and it's a brand and there is the
card out of course but these are real
numbers now yummy lore'l and Revlon and
you know Estee Lauder brands even do
that much not most so you know I talk
the reason I've been able to break
through a little bit Boehner is I go to
the highest levels and I only talk
business only business it's there all
CFO driven has nothing to do with the
CMO it has nothing to do with the CEO
just [ __ ] math and I just talk
business and the real business is the
retailers are taking all their money
because they're pouring all their money
into trade they're barely marketing
anymore and when they mark it it's not
working and listen the reason I don't
know where you work or what the exact
relationship but like I sit in these
meetings I've not sat with a traditional
creative shop that's playing around here
and watch them deviate anything from
30-second spots and the media company
forget about it they're not gonna let
you have any breathing room because all
their money is on programmatic and
television they lose money on Facebook
they lose money doing proper payroll
Google they lose money on influencer
that's going to PRP they're not going to
do that
got it
a hundred thousand percent and
profitable and profitable you know fun
it is to be a big hole it's the only
advantage of holding company has
vaynermedia has won the digital media
business from Chase from Mondelez from
tons of companies because that's done on
merit that's a skill you have to plan it
you have to just a creative like it's a
skill a holding company like a WPP and
Omnicom they just use their buying power
to get a better rate with CBS and ABC I
can't do that
so that's their advantage then the
upfront commit and then they force their
clients to spend on those platforms
regardless if it matters to them or not
it's it's it's yeah and and to enter
your yeah but I'll tell you this the
Facebook creative department I love a
lot of those characters but they're not
doing Facebook any favors they're
pushing things for Facebook they're no
different for example they tell
everybody in here to make sure the logo
is shown in the first three seconds
because they're reporting a brain lift
Studies is predicated on that it's the
worst thing you could do show a person a
brand in the first three seconds of a
video they're out make a video people
actually want to watch they're in we
made a Dunkin Donuts video that we got
[ __ ] on by Facebook by the client by the
incumbents by everybody and it [ __ ]
dominated because it was a music video
and it's [ __ ] funny and people liked
it and then when we retargeted the
people that watched two minutes and 12
seconds of it with a coupon they [ __ ]
converted because they [ __ ] were
happy with us because we did branding go
figure
yes sir what's your name it's because
they they model the mmm internally to
make that happen
a hundred percent
hundred percent the internal mmm so then
again one of the great things that
happen to me is I'm a business man that
came into the industry and every time
somebody would say something you know
I'll be honest with you I didn't come in
with an opinion about television I was I
thought it was me fun to make television
commercials and see them be like oh [ __ ]
I made that out like I get it when I
came in I was like your but of course
your internal mmm is measuring TV better
you made it that way like you made this
scale it's like saying a scale measures
your weight no [ __ ]
it didn't met like hey calories don't
matter cuz the scale measures your
weight really got it that's what it is
my friends like if you're not math nerd
about how they do
for example stuff seven oh you know what
what else happens there's a human
element to these mmm s so for example
when people tell you internal numbers
show a better row ads on TV or these
things do you know that a human being is
allowed to come in ninety nine percent
in time and say well it was what it was
too nice outside this weekend and so we
should adjust it by a couple percentage
points cuz it wasn't fair on TV because
it was sunny and people probably went to
the beach and so like you know for
creatives or like you know if you don't
look you don't know if you're not
educated like so yes it is propaganda
like everything in this world is built
to protect the most profitable things
for the holding company
the only way you could get somebody to
do something is make them aware of
something so whether you're telling
people to go under your shelter because
a tornado is coming or you want them to
buy a bandanna or a root beer it's the
same game the only game that matters is
attention it's the only currency that
matters because without it you can't say
your thing you're at the mercy this is
what makes me heartbroken for all the
beautiful and wonderful creatives in
this room and in this place nobody's
seen your [ __ ] so to me it's under
priced and over priced attention
everything's available if you have
unlimited money do everything because if
a billboards worth 800 dollars but you
paid ten thousand for it well you're
still gonna get some people to say it
but that's not the question at hand the
question at hand is when you have a
certain amount of budget what's under
priced and what's over priced to allow
you to hit the maximum reach the problem
is the industry is based on potential
reach not actual reach I understand how
many grps and how many homes could be
watching Empire or this playoff game I'm
asking you how many people actually
consume the commercial I know how many
times a video shows up in your stream
I'm asking you how many times has
somebody watched it here's what I know
we penalize things like Facebook and
Google where we can actually measure it
and we're rewarding platforms that we
can't we've accepted reports from 100
years ago that are big but they're not
real how are you measuring a radio spot
do you know how print is measured its
measured on circulation and a multiple
of when you bought when you make a print
ad for Vogue you were paying for eight
times the amount of Vogue's that are
printed that that page 98 is gonna be
seen by 8 times the amount of magazines
because the theory was magazines travel
and that when you left vogue on the bus
the next person picked it up and also
saw page 99 8 of them meanwhile in real
life
four of the billion people that possibly
read that thing ever get the page 99 and
actually look at that picture and really
consume it or you can go on Instagram
where every [ __ ] person on in the
world is living right now and looking at
[ __ ] people wearing clothes it's so
[ __ ] that they now charge more for
just internet because they need the fake
subscription numbers on cable to justify
the commercial Spence so they can go in
a conference to be like there's still 39
million people with [ __ ] that haven't
cut their cord no [ __ ] but none of them
are watching a [ __ ] commercial and
that's what we're talking about listen
carefully two years ago I was listening
very carefully to a lot of the talks
television isn't dead you know that
like Breaking Bad they said they talk
about shows they don't talk about
commercials and now it's over
OTT is gonna win we all know it I mean
think about your own could think about
but don't think about your conceptions
go and talk to 80 year olds
they're on Netflix in prime you know
what like what are people doing hi
okay okay sure
it's a great question I think the best
way to do it is produce an ungodly
amount of content and measure it over a
period of time so Facebook and Instagram
aren't going to tell you that there was
a lot of startups seven eight years ago
that we're trying to figure out the time
to post perfectly Facebook and Instagram
and others have shut down their api's to
really give you that data if you're a
smart publisher a brand ah so it's
interesting we're spending a lot of time
getting back to Twitter and like volume
content I think that you should just be
posting all the time and getting an
understanding of your audience and that
if you made an aggressive calendar for
90 to 100 days and then analyze the data
you will see patterns I don't agree with
that I think I think you should be
publishing for example let's use
Instagram since it's such a player right
now I think one man's point of view the
ideal amount of times that a brand
should post on Instagram on main feed
not stories is six in a day so let's
talk about it let's talk about it number
one first of all that's just organic
that's not even what I think you should
be doing on paid ads which is spending
all your money on it like all of it like
like you would be stunned how much I
think mow I think 80% of brands in
America should spend more than 60% of
their overall budget on Facebook and
Instagram 60 and I'm talking about
regardless of the brand because
Facebook's so deep now first of all you
have to understand something
for example my my Instagram I have 3.4
million followers on Instagram okay when
I post on my views on a video 200,000 to
500,000 right and that's what sharing
and people tagging you're not reaching
most of your audience to begin with so
if you're a brand that's posting six
times a day and your most interest and
what people don't understand about the
algorithm the algorithm that Instagram
and Facebook implement is the most
perfect and I mean perfect product I've
ever seen marketing you have to
understand why their interests align
with you the only thing Facebook and
Instagram make money on is you staying
on the platform so all of that unlike
television um
radio unlike print unlike websites that
put banners everywhere the entire
machine is built on you staying so if
you love a brand like Heineken you'll
probably see three of those because
you've shown through your actions that
you like it if you follow adidas and the
first seven posts don't tickle your
fancy and you don't engage you'll
probably only see one in every twelve
over two days of the organic posting so
you can't overwhelm on Facebook and
Instagram because Facebook and Instagram
is protecting you unlike email unlike
Twitter
unlike other platforms Facebook and
Instagram is not showing your creative
to all your people
organically No
yes newsfeeds been around for a long
time that's correct now you can set me
up I'll be right with you
you can set like if it's your best
friend or if you're a huge fan of
somebody you can set notifications and
they can force that and you'll see every
one but it is now filtered and has been
for a long time and is why you can do so
much more now the bigger conversation
for advertisers this is not now your
mom-and-pop store or you as a person is
you should be running ads the ads are so
under priced right now that you should
be running ads so if you're Adidas you
should be running ads against you know
Nike fans or against people that are by
aesthetic shoes or just 18 to 25 that
are into hip hop like a million things
you should be buying ads on for me
building anything whether it's a
personal brand or a brand or or a PSA or
anything of that nature it's just about
value exchange you know like what why do
I have a lot of followers on Instagram
because I motivate people and I give
them information that helps them with
their personal brand in business that's
a value exchange it's not because I'm
super hot other people other people have
3 million followers because they're
super attractive and we like attractive
people other people are great at sports
we love to see the highlight other
people are funny its value exchange I
want something you're giving me
something it's human nature you need to
figure out the single best thing that
you bring value in right and the problem
is most people don't like to give their
best work away for free that's what I
figured out I give I give away my all my
advice for free my best advice that
stuff I could sell for $1,000 ebooks and
$25,000 masterminds I give it all the
way for free because that is the
ultimate leverage because I'm bringing
the most value and I want the attention
because I think attention is the
ultimate asset got it and some an
incredible relationship when you hit
that crescendo I'm giving away all my
best [ __ ] you're giving me attention
which gives me leverage right gives me
permission to ask when I have a sneaker
out or a book or something right
I'll convert higher if I gave you a ton
of it like people literally buy [ __ ] for
me because they feel guilty like people
send me emails all the time like I
bought wine from your dad's like
Tarkus [ __ ] you know like you changed my
career and like you I haven't given you
a dollar so I [ __ ] bought some rose'
for my grandma like you know like you
know like if you really can and the
problem is most people don't know how to
provide value or let's be honest let's
really get there sometimes you just
don't have a lot - yeah you know I don't
know like it's a it's a you know what's
amazing about the new world is anybody
can do it
that's it means it's very competitive so
to break out you have to be like you
have to bring something but but you can
bring so many different things let's see
you can be just a good listener do you
know how big of a page you could build
right now on Instagram if you're just
like hey my Instagram is about like
listening like DME your problems I'll
just listen you'd be [ __ ] have 10
million followers tomorrow people want
to you know people need that you know
yes
you know it's funny I don't to your
point I think that's an interesting and
smart insight I I think that if they
don't have anything to say or aren't
making great creative like I think nine
years ago hey it's mother day worked on
Twitter because it was a novel team we
thought it was cool I don't think that
works as well now but let me tell you
this boy would I rather all the brands
that are running around here this
weekend pay an agency $800 for the copy
of that tweet versus the four hundred
eighty seven thousand for a commercial
that's bought on remnant inventory
commercial time that not one [ __ ]
soul saw so that's the thing right like
we scrutinized the new and we accept the
old and they're not even close
eight hundred bucks which would be
expensive if you pay five bucks but
agencies right eight hundred bucks to
say happy birthday you know or like
Father's Day yay right versus spending
five hundred thousand dollars with
widening Kennedy and then buying TV time
on CBS [ __ ] you you know the perfect
thing is what I think we did with Stella
Artois yesterday which was made two
minute 13 seconds cry you know like and
everybody here would want to make that
video because that's what you do and
that's what we do too it's just we
needed two minutes and 13 seconds first
of all to tell the story because the cut
down that they now want it's not gonna
be good
first of all snot to be seen and second
ball not gonna B's good it took us two
minutes and 13 seconds to get you to
care about the dad and the girl talking
about the dad for the punch line it
takes time to set up it's like telling a
comedian that's awesome it's stand-up to
consolidate it for 30 you need [ __ ]
three I gotta get you in it's like this
talk there's a way better talk in an
hour than it is in 30 seconds like I
gotta get you in I gotta create the
context that's what's so amazing all of
you want to do it because so many people
in advertising wanted to do film and
tell right like it's a it's a very
similar thing we now have it yet we're
not doing it
I knew at your agency
get across dishes that we have where we
have these large brands and all of these
regulations as far as when we're trying
to create content there is underage or
there's a million different we navigate
them like we don't break like if there's
you know if we can't tweet at Roger if
we can't use roger federer or
transformers or if you know we work on
Mondelez is candy if we can't market at
12 year olds and we work on Diageo and
ABI if we can't market under 21 those
are things we just navigate through your
preaching we don't we don't have that
scenario we don't we don't have it as
much because we think that that would be
the biggest waste of [ __ ] time
especially if it's organic you know like
if you're you know like to your point
like and I've seen in our building too
like why did we have a meeting for 40
minutes on a post that's gonna go
organic that eight people are gonna say
like you know if it's another thing
we're like we're getting you know I mean
we did a Budweiser video last year where
we dropped a container of beer in the
middle of a desert I mean I was a
million dollar production and we spent a
million dollars in media think that
should be debated that's money right
like but to your point I mean like even
on Twitter now where we think there's a
lot of fertile ground I'm going back to
the brands right now I'm like look we
need to be in the non approval game
can't be in the approval game you can
fire us but like to spend any time
debating if we're jumping into this
conversation about Wonder Woman is not
gonna we should be held accountable
we're your partner we know your rules
and your guard rails if we think we're
going close we may reach out be like hey
this is a little snarky but like
spending 45 minutes on a tweet that
we're hoping catches fire because we're
being close relevant waste of time it
starts from the top on the CEO of the
company and I set that tone for my
people and for our clients you know like
this the way I'm talking to you is the
way I talk to CEOs and CMOS like [ __ ]
you you're wrong and like we can either
work with us or not but like to
have pregnant is a bad idea yes within
your own organization it's tough and and
you know what I really really empathize
with for you guys a lot of your correct
creative like most senior creative
people she and he wants to come in at
the last minute and like and play that
card of ego it's just the subjective ego
like they're just rolling in at 1159 be
like not funny or you know like it's
just completely subjective you've got to
go through it like I'm pissed that I
have to deal with the subjectiveness of
the client you have to go within the
subjectiveness of your own organization
before you even get to the client suck
[ __ ] I think the way I think you know I
know the industry I think you try to
somehow one time set the tone of a very
like dear sir like do what it however
you want but whether it's dear sir or
like [ __ ] you lady like whatever you do
it you need to be like but don't you
think that's just based on your
subjective opinion now he and she is
more than welcome to say and that's why
I'm the chief creative officer and
that's what I'm here for what you know
and there listen that if you want to
know why I hate this place it's because
what I hear a lot of times is like well
I [ __ ] what I can Lyon like I [ __ ]
think Oscar Awards are subjective
[ __ ] what do you think I think about
this stuff you know but that is the
industry now let me tell you why I'm so
passionate for you to go home
start a private-label toothpaste
business that you buy in China buy a
thousand units put it on Amazon and
start creating on Instagram and Facebook
and try to figure out how to sell it
then you'll become self-contained and
then you can do your own [ __ ] because
otherwise there is no answer you it's
based on your culture I don't know your
company at Vayner our chief creative
officer Steve Babcock and the people
that work from know that if I ever hear
a whisper of them douching somebody on
their opinion they're in trouble I've
learned that
every other organizations the other way
right so but by the way that also hurts
vain or too because then what's happened
in our creative places that people are
scared to get feedback so we went you
know like you know this is human [ __ ]
right that's why my model what I want
for the industry is the best because all
13 of you could have your videos and
like could you imagine a creative world
where every idea do you know stupid it
is for you guys to spend four hours
smart brains teams white boarding the
ship have 13 ideas and then it's some
senior persons subjective opinion to get
him down to to present to a client the
client in a one-hour period who's really
she's running a business of selling
biscuits she's not a [ __ ] creative
she picks one of the two and then all of
the money goes into one 30-second video
that goes on TV that nobody watches yeah
I mean that example is just not fun
versus what I want which is you came up
with 13 ideas you look at all this
segmentations back to the genders and
the incomes like Budweiser means
something different to the 24 year old
in Atlanta that loves [ __ ] gucci mane
like you're like then it does to like 63
year old dick who loves rifles and
[ __ ] fishing and we can do both now
like a video of like a grandpa white
grandpa and Bama with his young white
grandson fishing and drinking Budweiser
targeted properly on Facebook the 63
year old you know Bama boy is gonna work
in the same way like the [ __ ] me goes
pouring Budweiser and a bunch of dancers
in the club is gonna work on 24 year old
Jerome like I don't understand what
people are doing here so I love the idea
of all 14 of your ideas for KitKat can
see the day of life
no more debating the [ __ ] internally
cool the one thing the senior creative
can say okay these six ideas we're gonna
make into 15-second video it's 19 second
videos 47 second videos for Twitter here
we're gonna do for Facebook this one is
a pre-roll on YouTube based on people
that buy skittles that we're gonna try
to convert because they search for
skittles on Google but we're gonna run a
pre-roll on YouTube for kick at being
like and the video was like you eat
skittles [ __ ] that KitKat like it's so
smart it works and yet we don't do that
and so like what's crazy is that I think
a lot of creatives
think I'm like not a good guy for
creatives because I come from a tech
world they think a math I come and [ __ ]
on everything and they don't like me and
I'm like listen I'm the one that's
[ __ ] gonna open up the creative world
I'm the one that's actually gonna make
it good for all of us I'm a creative
Nick came you know Nick's here he's
gonna win a thousand [ __ ] awards
tomorrow for this work with tide he's at
Vayner now like like he works with me
for like he's been here three months or
something like after the third mean he's
like you're the your creative I'm like
yeah but like that's how I got here
right like I know I'm not the creative
that David droga is to this industry and
I'll say this to David cuz we're
friendly like I'll outsell David every
day of the week every day the week and I
will make a video that'll make creative
and I'll do a pop I'll do creative but
mine's grounded in real life yes we
haven't heard from you yes great
question you know to me one of the
things we've done extremely well in a
couple of spots so we do plenty of
things that make me want to throw up on
myself but at our best the reason we
started if we have a 50,000 square foot
production facility in Long Island City
the reason we own our own production
facility is to drive down the cost of
creative so it can run the gamut my
belief is that copy and very dirty but
nice product I mean look guys you know
this you're not dumb you don't see your
friends or relatives or people on fiver
like you may not want to see it exists
because it [ __ ] with our world but you
can make some badass [ __ ] just on a
[ __ ] iPhone let alone can like like
that was another thing like I was like
how much do videos cost and advertising
I'm sure when you know I don't know
whenever you decided to be in this
industry but I'm sure the first time you
heard it seemed like a lot of money like
I don't know I have a funny feeling if I
hired all of you for a ninja team and
said by the way you have to make $15,000
videos
here's people you'd make some killer
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's plenty of [ __ ]
money I can do all sorts of damage for
that amount of money so we're just
driving down cost I think at its best I
think Twitter so vibrant right now again
that you can do a ton of copy see what
pops then make the ten thousand dollar
version right see if it goes and then
make the hundred fifty thousand three
hundred that that's the way
should be done not guessing on some
insights work coming into like you know
you know that's where I think insight
work and having the ability to hack
culture matter the most the to the
answer to a question in my brain goes
into two places true great insight work
which is not about interviewing three
people but really looking at big data
and big data is amazing like I hate that
word because everybody throws it around
because it's about analyzing big data
you know big data is real it's [ __ ]
special it's just an incredible talent
to look at all the cultural signals and
be like oh [ __ ] it's about insecurity
amongst 50 year old men on Thursday you
know that takes something right so big
insight work that gives you pillars and
then what I call culture hacking right
when things are happening in culture you
make creative quickly and see if that's
a place where your brand can play so I
think it's it's actually I think
everybody plays in the middle they go
into brain storming they're like okay
we're gonna we're gonna stand for
optimism or or we're gonna we're gonna
be utility or we're gonna we're gonna
own st. Patty's Day I'm more like you
know you got to go way deeper and be
like this is about moms being let me
give you an example of how I think about
insight work cuz I do a lot of it myself
a lot of parents right now want to blame
social networks for teen suicide teen
suicide if you do insight work has a lot
more to do with the fact that parents
are so over coddling their tip children
in the first eight to nine years of
their lives because parents are now so
deep in their kids [ __ ] they know
everything they [ __ ] ninth place
trophies anybody that gets picked on is
a [ __ ] catastrophe and it's gotten so
extreme that by the time a child is nine
and has never dealt with any adversity
by the time they start actually dealing
with adversity they're like a zoo animal
being put in the wild
that's insight work that wasn't so like
we didn't know that was happening that
we had to get there like oh [ __ ] so I'll
give you another one
I think non healthy foods are about to
explode foods with like sugar and like
because in a world where like [ __ ]
parents are worried about their kids
getting shot in school and heavy
political stuff all of a sudden giving
little Ricky a Twix versus some healthy
vegan [ __ ] tricked-out product
doesn't
seemed like the biggest issue that it
did six years ago and so now I see
insights that show me hmm this might be
the great era for sugar candy and food
and cereal to take a position of hate
like and here would be the pillar
however you would creatively manifest it
it would be hey mom in this world that
we now live in wouldn't it be nice to
just give Ricky a cupcake it's okay for
Ricky like you had a cupcake you turned
out okay like a cupcake would be okay
that's an insight that can really go
somewhere that you could really win with
a mom that's shopping down the aisle at
Albertsons so deep insight work and then
to that same mom you know Modern Family
gets cancelled and you've got a funny
perspective and you got a good
copywriter bangs in with some sort of
tweet it clicks and it becomes a whole
thing scandal starts blowing up and
you're the wine brand that owns drinking
wine during scandal you figured it out
cuz you're from Washington State and you
[ __ ] took advantage of Kerry
Washington being on the show
none of the Washington State wineries
did that they should have and they
should have done it through a lot of
copy and then that would have got it to
that see where I'm going
okay thank you yes
the mistakes are the best part when
you're producing as much this is Dirac
he's been filming me for three years
every day we put out a vlog we put out
tons of content the truth is almost all
of its mistakes that's the beauty of
that's what so scared why do you think
nobody wants to buy into creative from
my Silicon Valley world we could do all
this right and you can still spend three
hundred thousand on a video even though
it would have cost a million and it
would fail so through experience you
know what really and I mean this is not
thought out this I got I got real lucky
in my life experiences for example this
is really weird to bring up the
attention thing back to getting
goosebumps I is a six year old had six
lemonade stands tricked my friends into
standing behind the lemonade stands and
I would walk the streets of New Jersey
looking at cars looking at poles and
tree I mean I actually forgot about this
during a speech in real time because you
could see I kind of improv it I
remembered that this is what I used to
do I was I have such a natural trader of
attention that intuitively as a child I
understood that if I put my lemonade
sign on that tree versus that pole that
that would have an effect in hindsight I
didn't realize that's what I was doing
baseball card shows I was a big baseball
card dealer when I was 12 making a lot
of money they were big I'm old at the
time I used to walk the show for three
hours and set up my table after
everybody else because I would walk it
figure out the current as I used to call
it back then you know what was hot what
was happening and then I would go back
to my table and I would what I got it's
so funny to think about these days I
used to walk it I used to walk like make
pretend I was like a normal person and
be like what could I put on my table
that would stop you and then the
ultimate and I would tell you the great
thing he's so young you could still do
this literally work one year at retail
and watch their career change right I
see some of you shaking your head
I used to stand behind the register and
my dad's at restore and I would watch
people walk the store
later that became why I was so good at
UI and UX on the web because I'd already
and these are all things now I'm telling
you I didn't understand I was doing them
now I can reconcile it I wouldn't I mean
that's how I built my dad's store it
wasn't just marketing
it was wait a minute if people are all
going this way because that's how we set
up the store maybe I should put higher
profitable items why do we have the jug
wine there which is [ __ ] why don't I put
the good wine there you know and just
you know and at the register why don't
we these [ __ ] minis for alcohol which
would make a penny on let's put like
half bottles of champagne that are like
and people are picking them any of them
so the answer is because all I've ever
done has been obsessed about the
consumer for example when I put out
content now I don't watch other people's
content I don't even really think about
my own i watch how people react to my
content I read every comment I'm a deep
practitioner of consumer behavior in
action and that's what makes what you're
seeing what I do it's so natural I
pitched my full insights and creative in
rooms the whole thing to the point where
like when I started hiring grown-up
people in agencies they after they left
like no no no no don't do that like
that's what we have to get paid for to
present 8 weeks later I'm like oh [ __ ]
ok you know like like you know cuz it
comes so I'm so in tune because really
you'll find this interesting the word
that elevated to me is empathy
I've empathy a lot of it that's why I'm
a good CEO it's why I come into what I
come into this room only trying to bring
you value like I have empathy I know
what you're you know and that service me
well as a leader and a salesman and a
marketer and I deeply am religious about
it
Josh Josh pleasure
um it's great question so I don't
consume a lot but I'm grat I gravitate a
lot more to Vince McMahon and Walt
Disney I love people that can create IP
at a carrot I think Vince McMahon built
an incredible business model around IP
he gets people into characters like Hulk
Hogan and Andre the Giant there based on
humans and unlike being William Morris
or CIA or like a sporting League he owns
the IP it's actually [ __ ] brilliant
right like he creates in theory
superheroes out of humans and the human
can't take that IP with them like it's
really smart and then how he builds up
the storylines to get you to care very
interesting to me same with Disney like
I just think that he built an entire
universe so I like people that create IP
it's why I you know I don't know much
about it but I know enough to Satan here
it's why Leo Burnett in the 70s when
they were in 60s when they were creating
the Marlboro Man and Jolly Green Giant
and Keebler elves I have a lot of
respect for that I would say we just did
some work for bird's eye or something
where we have an avocado right like I
don't have to hit you guys radar like
I'm trying to push my agency towards but
Royal Bank of Scotland you're exactly
right we have two birds four Birds I
would makes a lot of more sense yeah I
mean Royal Bank of Scotland for our
London office we literally created an
avocado character if we hit it's forever
and I don't think we're taking those
risks and creative anymore we're trying
to make that video that makes you laugh
but we're not building IP and when you
build IP it's forever you know the Trix
rabbit is still here right
you know like MetLife pays peanuts a lot
of money for Snoopy you know Geico that
should matter so I'm variant that's what
I'm inspired by so I want to buy a
nostalgic brands that's why I was
obsessed with Marvel the comic book
company when it became a movie and I
mean it was a bankrupt comic book
company bankrupt comic book company
trillion dollar movie company you know
pretty cool I tried to buy animal
crackers from Mondelez a couple years
ago prematurely for me but it was such a
good deal
because I was gonna make an animated
film and I was gonna make America care
about the elephant I was like if
Madagascar an ice age matter I can get
every grandparent and older parent to
bring their kids to animal crackers
because they all grew up with those
crackers easy a storyline ever crackers
turn into life the way we go right you
know so that's what inspires me Gloria
yep how do you feel about love love love
the physical world obsessed as a matter
fact bener experience which is a
division we have for experiential is one
of my favorite projects my cheap heart
officer Claude silver is no question the
most senior executive besides me like
look like this is real we like here to
know otherwise we should just fire them
like like what are we doing here
like you know it I'm so pumped you asked
that because I'm so in it like I spent
an ungodly amount of time on HR I love
it I love it you know most people don't
want to especially the CEO especially in
my status want to be in the Karen is
ruining me business but I do I want to
know because it's how we can build I
think I can beat the whole industry by
giving a [ __ ] about people because they
can all the holding companies here can
because they're running financial
arbitrage models and every person is
just an a line item a hundred percent
and I'm trying to build forever
I look at Jason Nick Emily and Dirac and
like I only have one KPI can I keep them
forever
and that means a lot of things Emily's
on her fourth different thing in in our
organization right when Nick came over
there was a side hustle that he had that
I knew I had to be very in I spoke to
Bob memory for him for like an hour the
other day to make sure he over delivers
for Nick's campaign
Jason's switching now he pitched me a
music concept I listened I didn't
appease him in that 15 minutes we might
have started a music thing he decided to
go be a top production dog in the
publishing arms and that's just four of
them and I think the rock I like I'm
super close to because we're always
together the reason he's the easiest is
he knows me the best of the four of them
so I'm not I'll be very honest with you
I take him for granted the mode
because he knows exactly who I am as a
human being and I know anybody that
knows exactly what I'm up to I'm safe as
[ __ ] he may want to do other things but
he knows better than anybody right so
and that's four of them and of the 850
I know [ __ ] a ton of [ __ ] about 450
of them and the other 400 are just not
giving me the chance yet because they're
still cynical because they used to work
at Crispin yes of course not if I
entered this universe in 2001 my gospel
would have been emailing search can't be
the attention is gonna move it's why
we've gotten so big into voice it's the
first place that I see could be really a
powerful land grab and socials very act
you know kind of broad right to me it's
it's what platform lives on top of the
cell phone is what my Gospel actually is
the cell phone is the remote control it
is the place so and we've also thrown
things like YouTube and LinkedIn into
social right like the only social
network in my opinion is Twitter it's a
true social you know water-cooler
Instagram and Facebook have become
content platforms where you push yes
people can comment but most brands don't
go in there right so you know LinkedIn
my god I can't believe how serious we're
taking LinkedIn now I mean because
nobody else is my content is flooding
LinkedIn and a lot of my b2b world has
been built on that Andy and by the way
this is back to context one thing that I
told the team this is unheard of I never
filter I'm like hey guys I think we have
to start beeping my cursing on LinkedIn
I'm exploding but for so much of that
audience the cursing is really turning
them off and I have to respect that that
you're in a different room in LinkedIn
than you are on snapchat and what works
for you know 18 year old Sandra is not
playing for 64 year-old Joel as much and
so I have to be thoughtful of that and
even if it was Sandra like again this is
by the way this is the most interesting
thing about these platforms same person
different platform different person so
fascinating for me to watch that what
you're looking for you you're in Twitter
what you're we're gonna react to and
convert on one minute
leader you go into YouTube or LinkedIn
or Facebook and I've got to give you
some version at slightly different copy
wise so I love copy copy is the great
underrated thing right now you make a
great piece of creative if you change
the copy in all six platforms you know I
want you to edit the video but I know
how much money is involved in that so
just changing the copy on LinkedIn
versus Facebook versus Twitter versus
Instagram gives you a huge opportunity
and people spend so much time on the
actual asset but underestimate how
powerful that copy that associates it
can be and is who hasn't asked anything
let's you you sir
smart move about what my friend company
Morocco specializing in dairy products
keep going 30% of the company's owned by
a dirty dirty filthy politician for the
bad politician to not do the dumb [ __ ]
in the first place it's a very important
point and I'm not joking that's what I
love about the world we now live in you
know you know look I mean I think I
think the move it let's say that was my
cousin's business and 30 percent of the
company was a partner I would go on a
very heavy campaign alienating the
former partner and talking about the
product benefits but the reality is is
like that's the game we live in right I
mean you look at all rightfully so these
iconic you know personalities in the
u.s. going down on the me to movement
people you know people reaching out to
me behind channels saying hey how do I
protect against this I'm like yeah don't
the truth always wins it took a long
time but Christopher Columbus's brand
got affected you know what I mean like
the truth is gonna win and so I think
what the brand should do for the 70%
that are probably good people like [ __ ]
they need to alienate the for the
alienate and they may not want to do
that because in real life they may be
best friend like I don't know the
dynamics but what would I do in advise
alienate and then go aggressive on the
product values that of why it became the
leader in the category but step one is
alienated
against that individual because you have
to stop a pleading sure get the [ __ ] out
of here guys you guys are not young back
there I need you to leave your old
please get
[Music]